- What we'll do is we'll
get some random words
from different areas of the room.
Then we'll drop a beat and I'll do a rap.
If you are in this area of the room
what would you like a rap about?
- [Man] Samurai.
- Samurai? What is it about
samurai that interests you?
(audience laughs)
No, you didn't expect
to be probed further.
(audience laughs)
Kinda like a US gymnast
team doctor. (laughs)
- [Man] Swords.
- Okay, samurai swords.
Yeah, that's some good word association.
Samurai swords.
If you are in this segment,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Man] The Viking that discovered the US.
- The Viking that discovered the US?
Oh, yeah, I don't know if
you guys know about this
but there was evidence that
the Vikings had settlements
in America before Columbus came.
I mean obviously, none
of them discovered it
because, you know, Indigenous people
but yeah, Vikings cool.
(audience laughs)
Good.
Let's not let historical
facts get in the way
of a good comedy rap,
but the Vikings discovered
America will be fun.
People in the middle of the room.
So far we have samurai swords
and the Viking who discovered America.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Woman] Paul-
- [Man] Gay incest!
- Oh, okay, um...
(audience laughs)
Someone here was about to say something
and I wish you'd said it sooner.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] I was gonna say Paul Rudd.
- You were gonna say Paul Rudd?
- [Woman] Yeah! He's so wholesome.
- So wholesome. Yeah.
I'm trying to...
Is he in the new Ghostbusters
or something, like?
- No.
- Yeah!
- Well you just fucking "No",
and everybody here like "Yeah, Paul Rudd."
I don't know what he's in but okay, great.
Paul Rudd and gay incest, apparently.
Great. Let's come to this
final corner of the room.
Because that side, your
suggestion is gay incest.
And what would you guys...
Everyone's so upset about that.
(audience laughs)
That's your fault.
What would you like a rap about over here?
- [Man] Princess Di.
- Pardon?
- Princess Di.
Oh yeah, I mean, I guess
she's having a kind of moment
at the moment, init?
- [Audience] Oh fuck yeah!
- Okay, well, there's the movie.
Is it Kristen Stewart's in that movie?
- [Audience] Yeah.
- Is Paul Rudd in it as well?
(audience laughs)
Okay, Princess Di, gay incest, Paul Rudd,
samurai swords, and the
Viking who discovered America.
Alright well. This is going to be fun.
This is how we're ending the show.
We're doing a freestyle
rap about all those things.
It's not written, it's not prepared,
it's not rehearsed.
It's made up in the moment.
And don't worry, it will
not be anywhere near,
as atrociously, while
the beat gets playing,
embarrassingly, totally bad
as you are expecting it to be.
Maybe turn it up a little
bit more as well, if we can.
Why is it sounding weird?
It's been a while (indistinct).
Alright, let's close
that and try that again.
Just, imagine how good this rap would be
if we did a soundcheck. Oh man.
(audience laughing)
Okay, we'll try it one more time
and if not, I'll just fucking
put it through the microphone
and it'll sound less good
but it's going to be
a rap about gay incest
so it'll be shit anyway, won't it?
(audience laughs)
(upbeat music)
Oh, we got it!
We fixed it, nice.
Great, uh, so
Paul Rudd, gay incest,
the Viking who discovered
America, Princess Di,
and samurai swords.
It's what you asked for.
It's what you're gonna get.
I think we'll start with you.
Are you excited for this?
Yeah, 'cause it's your word.
It's your little phrase.
It's your little personal rap
about some Japanese dudes.
It's going to be...
You're not Japanese are you?
No, but that's fine.
♪ Don't worry, first thing
we spit about tonight ♪
♪ Coming from the man, not from Japan ♪
♪ I'm assuming that you're
white, kind of hard to see ♪
♪ The lights are low ♪
♪ Off to the far east, rising
sun you go, you better ♪
(tape squeals)
♪ Samurais ♪
♪ I mean they're mean ♪
♪ The facial hair, or the
masks, they're so clean ♪
♪ Like the blade, ♪
♪ It's mean sharp, made of steal ♪
♪ They get it out the scabbard
and they totally reveal ♪
♪ They're gonna, impale
any person coming there ♪
♪ See an enemy, then they're damn aware ♪
♪ Coming from the left and
the right with the swipe ♪
♪ I call it a Katana,
I hope you don't mind ♪
♪ If it's got a different
name that I'm not aware of ♪
♪ Put it back there, then I'm taking off ♪
♪ I wanna cut people down, only the guys ♪
♪ If a lady comes and
catch me by surprise ♪
♪ I won't kill her ♪
♪ Like Princess Di, it's very sad ♪
♪ Two years, 1995, that was 1997 ♪
♪ When Di went to heaven ♪
♪ She was over in Paris, yeah ♪
♪ I was like 11 years old, I was ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ I was maybe 8 ♪
♪ And a little tunnel there in Paris ♪
♪ She was going straight ♪
♪ Not there, by the paparazzi ♪
♪ They were like "Oh apologies, ♪
♪ Princess D, I, A, N, and the A ♪
♪ Wish that they had gone the other way ♪
♪ But what did she do in her lifetime ♪
♪ Divorce Princess Charles,
clear the landmine ♪
♪ She would walk around
with a metal detector ♪
♪ And everyone in war-torn countries ♪
♪ were like, "We respect ya ♪
♪ I hope you don't die
in an automobile chase ♪
♪ Sadly, she did, but
imagine the other place ♪
♪ Where she's still existing, inject ♪
♪ Maybe she would cure
the world of all incest ♪
♪ It doesn't really matter, either way ♪
♪ If the incest is straight,
or the incest is gay ♪
♪ Or the incest is bi ♪
♪ Princess Di doesn't even care ♪
♪ Whether it's a girl and a guy ♪
♪ Or a guy and a guy,
or a girl and a guy ♪
♪ Who mixes up with
another girl right inside ♪
♪ They'd be having so much sex ♪
♪ They'd be cumming with the blisters ♪
♪ Who are these people, me and my sister ♪
♪ Yeah I'll take her home,
and then I'll fist her ♪
♪ I once saw a woman,
yes, I can't resist her ♪
♪ Nice little rap about this plug ♪
♪ I've never seen much his movies ♪
♪ But Paul Rudd, he's amenable ♪
♪ Ever so likable, you
can watch his script ♪
♪ That he writes, quite recyclable ♪
♪ Why, 'cause they put him
in a franchise already made ♪
♪ Ghostbusters, if you
saw it you'd be dismayed ♪
♪ I know the fans liked it ♪
♪ They gave it a whirl ♪
♪ I prefer the one the thing
they made with all the girls ♪
♪ But they weren't related,
and having any sex ♪
♪ You could get a little
movie and put him on next ♪
♪ It's a pain in the neck ♪
♪ I don't know all of his franchises. ♪
♪ Last year all the Vikings arrive ♪
♪ It's coming over sea ♪
♪ They're like, what is it ♪
♪ They come in the
Atlantic not the Pacific ♪
♪ On the East Coast landed ♪
♪ Maybe north of the
border, maybe up in Canada ♪
♪ Columbus was a hoarder in the 1400s ♪
♪ Trying to steal all the shit ♪
♪ But the Vikings, they were there ♪
♪ On their big dragon ships, coming over ♪
♪ See a little Indian village and said ♪
♪ Ah, we're gonna rape and pillage ♪
♪ And the Indians ran away
scared of the swords ♪
♪ The Vikings came, and the
helmets didn't have horns ♪
♪ But they weren't actually
the first to arrive ♪
♪ Who got there first, some
fucking samurai, yeah ♪
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)